Some classes in the OMS
program have proctored exams.
A proctored exam is similar to one
you would take in the classroom.
No books, no notes, no resources,
just you and the test.
Now, of course, in a classroom,
that's easy to do.
There is a teacher watching.
Online, it's not so easy, so we use a
tool called Proctortrack, which provides
automatic proctoring using cutting
edge AI and computer vision.
And that's fascinating to me.
We're using AI and
computer vision to deliver a program
where you'll learn about AI and
computer vision.
>> To access Proctortrack,
you'll go to testing.verificient.com
as you see up here.
When you first take a class
that has a proctored exam,
a Proctortrack account will
be created for you here.
And you'll get the password
in your email.
Using that login name and
password, click here to log in.
After logging in,
you'll be back at the home page.
Click View Tests to view
the tests available to you.
Generally, the first time you log in,
you should see an onboarding test.
Click Continue to open
the onboarding test.
Then walk through the steps to install
the software on your computer for
the first time and
experience what proctoring is like.
When you have an upcoming test,
it will be listed here as well.
>> Note that even after you've
taken the onboarding test,
it will continue to appear here just in
case you need to set up the software on
a new computer in the future.
And as with other tools we use,
Proctortrack may change over time.
So check the notes below
this video to see if there's
anything new to be aware of.